[Música]
kiev anunció la retirada de sus tropas
de la ciudad de leeds y chance después
de que rusia asegurará tener el control
de toda la región de lugansk tras ganar
precisamente la batalla del dif chance
la que era hasta ahora el último bastión
de las tropas ucranianas en esta región
del donbass
crece la tensión entre israel y líbano
el ejército israelí acusó al grupo
extremista libanés hezbollah de intentar
atacar con drones un campo de gas en
alta mar en el mediterráneo
el gobierno israelí de yair lapid
aseguró que la acción empaña las
negociaciones entre ambos países sobre
la frontera marítima conjunta
los líderes del áfrica occidental
decidieron levantar las sanciones
impuestas a mali una decisión tomada en
gana en la reunión de la cedeao que gira
en torno a los golpes de estado en malí
guinea y burkina faso los 15
representantes de la comunidad económica
regional se declararon comprometidos a
perseguir el regreso de estos países al
orden democrático
buenas tardes bienvenidos a las noticias
de france 24 en español soy rosa pérez
masdéu y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles empezamos esta edición
informativa con información sobre el
desarrollo de la guerra en ucrania el
ejército de kiev anunció la retirada de
sus tropas de la ciudad de leeds y chang
en la región de lugansk una retirada que
llega tras el anuncio de moscú de hace
unas horas en que reivindico tener el
control total de la región de lugansk la
ciudad del isdi chang representaba hasta
ahora el último bastión de las fuerzas
ucranianas de lugansk por lo que las
tropas de kiev intentaron evitar durante
días esta derrota después de haber
perdido la vecina ciudad de severodonezk
hace una semana
[Aplausos]
blandiendo banderas rusas chechenas y
soviéticas se oye a estos combatientes
decir que han entrado en y si sanz los
vídeos fueron publicados en telegram por
ramzán kadyrov el líder de chechenia y
un aliado clave de vladimir putin los
vídeos corroboran las afirmaciones
hechas por rusia el viernes
las fuerzas armadas rusas siguen
avanzando con éxito en la región de
listas aunque en los últimos tres días
se ha establecido el control sobre una
planta de procesamiento de combustible
una mina y una fábrica de gelatina el
ejército ucraniano está sufriendo
grandes pérdidas en esta región
el sábado un portavoz separatista dijo
que el isi suns que estaba completamente
rodeada mientras rusia intensifica sus
ataques contra la ciudad muchos
residentes ya habían hundió
la ciudad ya no existe ha sido
prácticamente borrada de la faz de la
tierra ya no hay ningún centro de
distribución de ayuda humanitaria ha
sido golpeado
y
muchas víctimas yo fui una de ellas
estaba cubierta de escombros la gente me
ayudó a desenterrar me el domingo el
ministro ruso de defensa anunció
finalmente la liberación total de la
región de lugansk tras la tomada del isi
suns la última gran ciudad que seguía
bajo control ucraniano en la región su
conquista ahora abre las posibilidades
para el ejército ruso a avanzar hacia
asilo bians y crematorio otras dos
grandes ciudades de tumbas que moscú
tiene en el punto de mira
y precisamente para abordar la
importancia de la caída de la ciudad del
distance acá manos rusas como factor
clave en el desarrollo de la guerra
hablamos previamente con martín
rodríguez osés él es internacionalista y
especialista en temas de rusia el
primero de los objetivos regionales de
esta misión especial que han establecido
los rusos en el que buscar el control
total de tanto lugares como de danny
está así que ya estaría cumplida la
primera parte y todo indica que se
tomaría la región de dones en
relativamente poco tiempo para las
expectativas de ucrania y de sus aliados
occidentales la toma de hecho decisión
tomó menos tiempo de lo que se esperaba
porque los rusos estaban tratando de
cruzar un río que separa a cero en es
desechado y les haya tomado su tiempo
pero lo han conseguido y hoy tiene una
concentración de fuerzas muy grande por
lo que es esperable que tomen
el resto de la región en menor tiempo de
lo esperado lo que hay que ver ahora es
si ese avance va a ser este
causado por algún tipo de ataque
ucraniano como se dio en el goro que es
territorio ruso
y traten de hacer divergen digamos los
objetivos en el terreno lo cual no logré
continuamos en ucrania porque vadim el
yak el alcalde de la ciudad oriental
ucraniana de lugansk reportó el
bombardeo más intenso registrado en la
zona desde el inicio de la guerra según
los medios locales varios ataques con
lanzacohetes dejaron al menos 6 muertos
y cerca de 15 heridos esta ciudad de
mayoría rusófona y conocida como el
corazón industrial de ucrania podría
convertirse en el próximo objetivo de la
ofensiva rusa en el donbass
continuamos con información relacionada
con la guerra en ucrania al menos tres
personas murieron y cuatro resultaron
heridas mientras decenas de residencias
fueron destruidas por explosiones no
reivindicadas en bélgorod una ciudad
rusa ubicada a 40 kilómetros de la
provincia ucraniana de kharkiv ucrania
aseguró que investiga las causas de las
explosiones pero rusia acusa
directamente a kiev de aurel tiene los
detalles
la ciudad rusa de bélgorod amaneció con
el sonido de fuertes explosiones que
dañaron a 11 edificios de apartamentos a
39 casas particulares y que destruyó
completamente a una casa según el
gobernador de la región los residentes
atestiguan de la fuerza del impacto el
techo se derrumbó y la bola de fuego no
me di cuenta de la bola de fuego porque
ella estaba histérica levanté a mi hijo
y nos arrastramos justo sobre el cristal
así como si estuviéramos nadando salimos
a la calle yo me estaba levantando en
ese momento y fui lanzado hacia la
puerta por la ola explosiva los
cristales de las ventanas salieron
volando mi espalda
estas explosiones serían producto de los
desechos de tres misiles que según moscú
fueron disparados por ucrania y
derivados por los sistemas de defensa
aérea rusos
quiero enfatizar que este ataque con
misiles fue planeado y llevado a cabo
deliberadamente contra civiles en
ciudades rusas
los activos de defensa aérea rusos
destruyeron en el aire los tres misiles
balísticos que estaban equipados con los
ivas de racimo y fueron lanzados por los
nacionalistas ucranianos contra el corot
desde el inicio de la ofensiva de
músculo en ucrania rusia acusado varias
veces a las fuerzas ucranianas de haber
efectuado ataques en territorio ruso
especialmente en esta región de bélgorod
a sólo unos kilómetros de la frontera
con ucrania
seis personas murieron y ocho resultaron
heridas tras el desprendimiento de parte
del glaciar de la marmolada en los alpes
italianos de momento no se descarta que
pueda haber varios desaparecidos a esta
hora se lleva a cabo la evacuación de la
zona mientras continúan las labores de
búsqueda con cinco helicópteros y
unidades caninas el accidente se habría
producido cerca de la punta roca en la
vía de ascenso de la ruta habitual para
llegar a la cumbre donde había varios
senderistas
continuamos con otra información en
desarrollo también en europa en este
caso en dinamarca donde este domingo una
persona ha irrumpido en un centro
comercial de la capital copenhaguen y ha
abierto fuego contra los presentes la
policía danesa informó de que varias
personas han resultado heridas en el
tiroteo y de que han arrestado a un
hombre en conexión con los hechos
insistimos esta es una noticia en
desarrollo que continuaremos ampliando
y el gobierno de israel acusó al grupo
extremista el libanés hezbollah de
intentar atacar con drones una
plataforma de gas israelí situada en
aguas reclamadas por ambos países el
episodio amenaza con incrementar las
tensiones sobre la ubicación de esta
plataforma así como los esfuerzos para
acordar una frontera marítima entre
israel y líbano
estas imágenes publicadas por las
fuerzas de defensa israelíes el sábado
pretenden mostrar el momento en que tres
drones disparados por el grupo libanés
hezbollah fueron derribados dijeron que
los drones se dirigían al campo de gas
de caris a menos de 100 kilómetros de
las costas de israel hezbollah confirmó
el incidente el sábado sin decir que los
drones habían sido interceptados el
sábado por la tarde 3 drones desarmados
fueron lanzados hacia el disputado
campus de caris para realizar misiones
de reconocimiento la misión fue cumplida
y el mensaje fue recibido líbano e
israel que comparten fronteras se han
enfrentado en los últimos años por los
recursos del mar las tensiones
aumentaron el mes pasado cuando un buque
fletado por israel operado por una
empresa griega entró en el campo de
caris e instaló una plataforma
provocando una rápida respuesta des bola
télam
la empresa griega y sus propietarios
deben saber que son socios de la
agresión que se está produciendo en el
líbano en estos momentos
nuestra la instó además a las
autoridades israelíes a esperar a que
las negociaciones que cuentan con la
mediación de eeuu den sus resultados las
negociaciones se han estancado en los
últimos años mientras los dos países que
están oficialmente en guerra se disputan
las lucrativas reservas de energía
vamos ahora al continente africano
porque los líderes de áfrica occidental
se han reunido en accra la capital de
ghana para revisar su plan de acción
frente a las juntas militares que han
tomado el poder en malí guinea y burkina
faso de hecho los miembros de la
comunidad económica de áfrica occidental
acaban de anunciar el levantamiento de
sanciones a bamako después de que las
autoridades militares malienses se
comprometieran a celebrar elecciones
legislativas en octubre de 2023 y
presidenciales en febrero de 2024 vamos
con el informe
qué posición hay que adoptar frente a
las tres juntas militares en el poder en
malí guinea y burkina faso tras el
fracaso de la primera reunión celebrada
hace un mes en ghana se espera que los
líderes de la cedeao adopten una postura
en el caso de malí el único país con un
embargo económico total durante seis
meses los últimos hechos han allanado el
camino para que se relajen las sanciones
el miércoles bamako hizo público el
calendario electoral que había exigido
la cedeao cuyos dirección legislativa
para las elecciones legislativas la
primera vuelta será el domingo 29 de
octubre de 2023 la primera vuelta para
elegir al presidente de la república
será el domingo 4 de febrero de 2024
you need to caps dos semanas antes se
había aprobado una nueva ley electoral
he creado una comisión encargada de
redactar una nueva constitución un
referendo constitucional que está
previsto para marzo de 2023 anuncios
calificados como enormes progresos por
el equipo de goodluck jonathan el ex
presidente nigeriano que está mediando
entre la junta maliense y la cedeao
hasta ahora a guinea conakry burkina
faso sólo han sido suspendidos del
organismo pero a diferencia de mal y
ahora los dos países se exponen al
endurecimiento de sus sanciones en ambos
casos el anuncio de un período de
transición de 36 meses no ha gustado a
los dirigentes de la cedeao desde guinea
conakry han intentado mostrar buena
voluntad para evitar el destino del
vecino maliense ya hemos creado un
consejo interministerial a un grupo de
es que lo perfeccionaremos a medida que
avancemos mientras desde la oposición
guineana piden un mediador del organismo
en burkina ya ha nombrado a un mediador
el ex presidente nigeriano o mamadou
issoufou el sábado estuvo en uagadugú
donde se celebró la apertura el diálogo
de los militares burkineses pero la
propuesta electoral de la junta con un
referendo constitucional en diciembre de
2024 y elecciones en febrero de 2025
está demasiado lejos para la cedeao
cambiamos de nuevo de información vamos
ahora a oceanía porque este domingo en
australia el gobierno local de sydney
ordenó la evacuación de miles de
residentes del suroeste de la ciudad una
medida de precaución frente a las
intensas lluvias que desbordaron presas
y ríos en la zona costera de nueva gales
del sur el ministerio de servicios de
emergencia advirtió sobre el riesgo
inminente que corren los habitantes de
la región por lo que pidió a los vecinos
de las zonas afectadas que consideren
cancelar sus planes de viaje para las
vacaciones escolares con el phising
enfrentamos peligros en múltiples
frentes inundaciones repentinas
inundaciones fluviales y erosión costera
soy firme y bien y por lo tanto se bebe
en cualquier lugar entre newcastle y
weithman se ve y no se deje atrapar por
la situación climática actual esta es
una situación de emergencia
potencialmente mortal training y
machines y situación y cerramos con
información deportiva desde dinamarca
donde culminó este domingo la tercera
etapa del tour de francia con el
ciclista de países bajos dylan gray
niegan como vencedor la jornada de hoy
se disputó a lo largo de un tramo de 182
kilómetros sobre llano que inició en
relé y terminó en son der borght de
momento el belga bart continúa vistiendo
el maillot amarillo